bit nigeria's vice president for setting
governors and former cabinet ministers
to the ticket
critics say he's too old
but tinibu who co-founded the coalition
that brought the old people's congress
and president muhammadu buhari to power
seven years ago
insists he's fit for the job
the competition is now over
those who did not support me
you have nothing to fear
i don't know jesus
the decision by governors from the north
to support a candidate from the south
has narrowed down the choices for
delegates the governing party and its
candidate will now have to unite
other former hopefuls and their
supporters ahead of nexus general
elections tinibu is from southern
nigeria a region many fields should
produce the next president after buhari
and odana has served out his two terms
there was confusion ahead of the
election when some senior party
officials were accused of trying to
force through another nominee prompting
president buhari to address members
we must avoid acrimony
and maintain the secret of sports
mentioned
chinebu supporters believe they've got
the right person
it will possibly have all of the you
know
reserve you know skills and knowledge to
comfort you know and help the country
you know in all of the major challenging
areas that we have
but political analysts say this could be
the man standing between tinibu and the
presidency atiku abubakar won the main
opposition's primaries at the end of may
his run for nigeria's top office five
times and describes his election as
historic
a history
which we believe
will bring about
fundamental changes
in governance
and also in our political processes
our workers supporters say after eight
years as the opposition the people's
democratic party is ready to govern
again it is a win
to redirect nigeria to rebuild nigeria
it is a way to rescue nigeria
the apc primaries were held just before
the deadline for parties to register
candidates for the february vote and
although other presidential hopefuls
will be in the running nigerians will be
watching the race between these two
political giants
al jazeera abuja